for human beings because of Technology
because of all these advancements we're
not trying to enforce these things that
if we were to leave it to actual nature
it would actually phase out
hermaphrodites as they were called and
we now call them differently have
existed since the dawn of doing yes they
haven't been eradicated
Adam and Eve when the point is
in nature if you had to leave everything
to show and take signs out of it and
leave everything to nature of how we're
designed for one eventually the long
enough time span gay people can
reproduce transsexuals or whatever would
eventually die out if you had to leave
everything to Nature and human beings
when you go to Tampa